faire connaître le dos médical c'était
l'objectif de ces intervenants de la
santé ce mardi 11 octobre au théâtre de
saint quentin en yvelines organisée en
partenariat avec la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des ivy nelly ps
l'institut de promotion de la santé la
réunion d'information était centrée sur
le don du sang de plaquettes et
d'organes crois qu'il faut c'est comme
une porte il faut il faut la pousser un
peu plus facilement et et s'engouffrer
dedans c'est donc effectivement faire
connaître des sites fixes qui sont les
nôtres parce qu'on a beaucoup plus de
mal pour recruter les donneurs c'est
important de faire connaître
au public le la loi et les problèmes que
nous rencontrons aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines le don d'organes est effectué
dans les hôpitaux de poissy saint
germain en laye de versailles la réunion
d'information a permis de clarifier la
loi sur ce sujet méconnu du grand public
la loi dit que nous sommes tous des
donneurs présumés et donc si on est
opposé au don d'organes ou de tissus de
son vivant il faut vraiment le dire
on peut aussi s'inscrire sur le registre
national des refus et si on est pour on
peut prendre une carte mais légalement
ça n'a pas de valeur donc le plus
important c'est vraiment on entend
parler à ses proches à sa famille parce
que c'est vers eux qu on se tournera si
vous arrive quelque chose pour savoir si
vous étiez d'honneur au point en france
6000 greffes d'organes sont effectués
chaque année pour environ 20000
personnes qui sont sur liste d'attenté
les donneurs peuvent effectuer un don
sans limite d'âge